sorry the show is presented by on it
the days are back the church of what's
happening now is proud to introduce you
to hellotushy.com that's hellotoshi.com
hellotushy.com makes portable devices
that spray your butt clean with water go
to hellotushy.com church right now go
there right now and get 10 off of your
order it's a stuffing stuff it's a
stocking stuffer and nobody wants to
have a dirty [ __ ] on christmas eve
and i think we can ship it to you there
just let them know we'll figure
something out hellotushy.com
it's the best
the show is also brought to you by
headspace headspace is meditation made
simple download the free headspace app
and begin their take 10 program for 10
days of guided meditation at
headspace.com joey that's headspace.com
joey
oh [ __ ]
here we go
five days
shoplifting left let's do this [ __ ]
crank that mule lee
kick that lead
what's the story in this [ __ ]
mickey girl is in the house tonight
fresh off sacramento
[ __ ] with a future i was telling
somebody today if somebody said to me
they could turn back my life
i would go i'll start from 30. like i
wouldn't want to do my 20s over
if i had your 20s i'd do it all over i'm
loving it you're loving it
congratulations thank you thank you you
deserve it the way you did it very nice
thank you very smooth thank you it was i
honestly i i never saw the show so i
watched it i watched it today because i
i had seen you with my first uh fight
watching it with cm punk and then i
watched it today and i
joey talks a lot about about this time
in your life like the early the mid-20s
and i was just thinking like it was like
a year ago right and now you're three
fights in the uf like you were going you
were like the biggest fighter i saw
everyone had this shirt like you're the
only guy in the in the show who had an
act like sponsors and a shirt those
sponsors must be
so happy like they they must have made 8
000 times their return off of that video
because
like you were just it was in philly
right like a local philly show and
you're from jersey
and you went in there and destroyed it
was awesome it was like it was cool to
see and then a year later three fights
ufc fights yeah three and a half [ __ ]
surreal huh crazy
crazy quick what does your family think
they're having fun they like it
um yeah my
yeah my actually i'm surprised you don't
know my dad
you guys grew up right around the same
time he's 53 also
you were talking about you were talking
about uh pulling scams at the english
town uh auction yeah that's where he
used to go yeah he grew up in an
elephant
now how far is that from english town
close he used to work there like he had
that was like his first job the funny
races and all that yeah those selling
you know selling [ __ ] the mall there it
was an outdoor thing and everything was
stolen mickey yeah it was 19 [ __ ] 75.
there was no cops
there was no legislation yeah there was
no kmart there was no walmart there was
no
where do you go to get returns
you know like when you what's that store
you go to uh marshall cj maxx with tj
maxx that it's you know there's a
stitching that's wrong that's why you're
getting two thousand dollar pants for 42
dollars because the stitching is wrong
let me ask you a question we're from
jersey give me those [ __ ] things you
know
so in those days all that [ __ ] in
english town and i lucked out on that
like that that was a friend of mine who
said let's take a ride to english town
and we walked around buying eight tracks
eight tracks were cheap they were stolen
they weren't stolen they were duplicated
they did what columbia house did
and sold them to you for a dollar give
me give me 12 for ten dollars are you
[ __ ] kidding me in those days i
remember going there my grandma yeah
yeah it's still there yeah
i yeah when i was little i go there all
the time now it's still on saturdays and
sundays i think so yeah i've been in
years
but uh yeah i remember you would hear
the crappy looking nikes but they they
weren't nikes
yeah bootleg stuff all bootleg stuff but
that was then
but uh that was now
then there was a place
that had converse close by
that's how the whole thing went down
there was a dumpster of sneakers
and you would go in there the only
problem was you got to find the match
that other [ __ ]
that's where the time consumption was
so you just took a bunch out and kept
throwing them out throwing them out and
you put them in the car and you sorted
them out when you got home sometimes you
did better than others sometimes you
said let's go back in that dumpster and
get the matches
because you had to get the match it was
and these days there were the julius
irving sneakers and they called them
limousines for defeat and they were
maybe 22
but
you could get them at englishtown for
seven
so these guys would actually go to
dumpsters jump and then bring the [ __ ]
to english town and sell them for seven
[ __ ] dollars i would take them and
sell them for 15 in north burger what
are you kidding me like a doctor they
didn't know there was stitching and
nobody knew that they made mistakes
converse was [ __ ] converse you know
but
everything
they had rims in those days down there
they had like [ __ ]
radios for your cars like real expensive
radios and they weren't stolen out of
cars it was stuff that was hijacked off
trucks
that's all it was and everybody knew it
was hot stuff and [ __ ] who gave a [ __ ]
it's english town new jersey [ __ ]
what was it like a store like a outside
market outside flea market
equivalent to the slauson what do they
do here
what do they do here that you went to
swamp meme the swap meet
that's the same [ __ ] thing what's a
swap meet down there people go down and
sell what they i think so i i don't i
only went there for like cruise and
stuff like that yeah
i think they sell like random store
space i guess i guess you can do
whatever you want
that's crazy have you seen like in other
countries they have that but they'll
have like like when i went to israel
they'll have like barber shops in those
places they have like everything you
need in the local market
it's pretty quick crazy
they both have to go to israel and show
those [ __ ] what it's all about
you know how do you when you first
started
um well you started taekwondo like
everybody else no i um i grew up like
playing all the sports football baseball
basketball um when i was 13 i started
boxing i'd have like my dad would drive
me like six in the morning on a saturday
and like drop me off there
um and i go it was in a fan wood
so like like you know like the playing
fields yeah yeah um
it was uh
the dude used to train lennox lewis
harold shadow knight him his brothers
had a gym so like it was a good spot uh
but you know i wasn't so consistent then
then i started doing jiu jitsu and i was
16
and that i took to that like to do mma
so eight years been doing jiu jitsu like
like seven eight years training for mma
jesus christ yeah
and most people just go on those
circuits local circuits for a while and
they go like seven eight fights
yeah then that's the path i expected to
take right then the ufc then the your
manager sends you tape to the ufc yeah
or you guess yeah something like that
you had him come into your town or him
coming to that fight and
he came to my debut i figured i would
have had to beat like you know seven or
eight beat up seven or eight more guys
regionally and then i get my again the
ufc it's a [ __ ] dream come true yeah
that's a dream of a comedian
to go on stage and to be a director in
the thing and often you're perfect for
his movie and you get in the movie that
was the dream you know whatever but it
was the dream for you which is [ __ ]
dynamite so you went from a
to z like you [ __ ] one day yeah it
went from then you called that cm punk
and you had a plan yeah right as i found
out right i found it like a month before
the owner called me and i was like i
have big news
dana white said get the fight and i was
like all right so how do i make the most
of this it's like boom i called that
dude cm punk i'll beat my guy i'll be
one to know cm punk's oh no that's a
like record like that fight can happen
so i was like you know who i figured
everyone would be doing it like it
seemed so obvious i'm not gonna call out
robbie lawler they'd like shut up idiot
you know so i was a smart move man
yeah so i just got on mics i love to
fight him i didn't think anything was
gonna happen with it and then a month
later i was watching ufc my dad and they
show a commercial for the looking for a
fight show and it was like me talking i
was we're like what we like recorded the
tv screen with our phones
it was wild
it was the one thing i noticed is
when you guys were like shaking dana's
hand after the fight there was this one
guy and i'm sure he was great and i
think he won but he's like was it on or
to fight in front of you dana like it
was an honor i hope to find in front of
you again sir and you were like want to
know give me cm punk [ __ ] and he was
like he responded to that like you would
think maybe like oh i should be
respectful to the owner of the ufc and
you're like want to know give me
something
now was it i think i said well you don't
say you didn't say [ __ ] didn't say
[ __ ] but you said like one i i was like
hey wanna know man that that [ __ ]
happened
no i wasn't gonna be disrespectful dude
no you weren't disrespectful but you
were confident you weren't you weren't
like okay kissing the ring or whatever
however you want to say it and it was
just it was interesting to see that he
and even the last
the ending clip of the show is i'm
interested yeah like that's like that he
you obviously caught his attention you
know sometimes not what you say is how
you say it man yeah and if the dude's
cool he feels your passion he feels you
you're in like flint you know it's it's
so easy
it's like when uh
who's the heavyweight champion stoick
uh steve bamioche
the one time when he fought he just went
after dana you know and he did it in a
certain way
that you could see it was his heart like
he's like enough is enough yeah i [ __ ]
give me that yeah give me that [ __ ]
belt i [ __ ] up everybody already you
know if you don't ask for it they're not
going to give it to you guys close mouse
don't get fed you know if you walk up
there and go higher i'll find whoever
the corporation puts in front of me
that's great you didn't do dick every
time you fight if you have a successful
uh tremendous [ __ ] win like the last
two you had
you got to go out there and sling dick
you know half of this game is mental
you know i like when people go a month
after mickey's gonna fight in september
who do you like i don't [ __ ] know
i'll tell you after the weigh-in
i'll tell you after the weigh-in for me
when i used to go to wayne's with joe
i'd see [ __ ] that was crazy and in my
mind i'd make a mental note the next
thing you know i'm like i didn't bet it
i didn't bet it because you start
learning that that fight is one
right there at that weigh-in with the
mind you could it's how he reacts to it
sometimes
so come out and call somebody the [ __ ]
out they'll be home watching the same
fight you're watching giggling yeah and
next thing you know dana's got you both
on the phone if you keep winning they
got to keep giving the guys the ass for
yeah it's playing in that that's that
plain and [ __ ] simple
a man without a plan is not a man you
know
listen man i didn't know this
the expectancy of a [ __ ] running back
is three years three years yeah i never
[ __ ] knew that okay i never knew that
fact that's a fact because we look at
people
that go for six or seven years
we don't see the medium range guys that
play three games and blow out their
knees
now they're out for a year then they
come back and play that dude for the
giants what's his name we break his neck
like david wilson yeah he had to retire
his name he was like rookie of the year
or like the one the number
one draft pick yeah like and then yeah
he's like a year or two was supposed to
be like the next like our next running
back out
bad neck career over and you don't even
those are the ones that you see but like
like joey was saying a lot of times like
sometimes because i used to be a big fan
i used to have a lot of time when i was
young and you see these people get
drafted especially quarterbacks you see
them get drafted and a year or two later
they're selling real estate or they're
just just because
they don't get any chance
like it's crazy
our our good buddy uh nate boyer who
came on when he was like i think wasn't
he like
he's still lurking oh yeah he's still
around but yeah it was just
it's uh
it's
there's so little
so few jobs and it's it's too
competitive it's so weird now
even
in uh you're a young man you're 24
but you remember george saint pierre
hell yeah like a lot of people don't
like when i heard this a couple weeks
ago that
a lot of people don't remember who
that's how much new fans have gotten
okay
the whole crew maybe even a little
before conor mcgregor they don't even
know who who gsp is
right now mma ufc is moving really fast
yeah you're on a fast [ __ ] uh moving
track right now
and
you're intelligent as [ __ ]
because you have a plan you know always
say lee what do we always talk about
being [ __ ] what's that word you
saying that uh calculated calculated
that's that's big and it's tough to be
calculated at a young age yeah to have
the control you have all the weapons you
know wow did was doing jujitsu at 16
help that because you really it seems
like that would be it probably yeah
probably yeah that that problem solving
and stuff like that thinking ahead
i i've always been smart not to you know
to my own horn but
yeah my my uh my jiu jitsu coach real
strategic guy david adive
he's like israeli special forces jiu
jitsu black belt like seventh degree
so yeah yeah he's a serious dude he
instilled that in me a little bit too
long am i with my
dad it's just really weird that uh
when you start fighting playing football
you wrestle especially from the area
we're from
you have so many [ __ ] knuckleheads
you know and and
a lot of people uh
punch hard you know they gifted with the
gift of punching hard they got a purple
belt in jiu jitsu they get a tattoo
they fight three times they go three you
know
they do a couple shots of deck of the
roblin to really make them crazy they do
some ecstasy some weekends
sweat it out some more steroids you put
that whole mix together with the tattoo
ink you're [ __ ] you understand me
you're [ __ ] and they go into a
situation or they go 3-0 with knockouts
they hit really hard
but they go into the ufc
with that i'll just start knocking
people out and you run into damien meyer
technique and now you it takes two years
to get out even up to close to going in
that [ __ ]
momentum with damian maya you're so
[ __ ] well-rounded
you're so well-rounded right off the
[ __ ] bat that's what really scared me
especially after watching you saturday
i go wait a second and you have control
so you have all the weapons right there
it's just a matter of
a man without a plan is not a man
nietzsche you follow me sir
you got it
that's it and the rest is about jersey
who gives a [ __ ]
it's all about jersey
that's where you learn how to take a
beating
oh my god i got beat up so many times in
jersey i never got beat up down the
shore though i didn't cause problems
down this show i was a little smarter
than that were you getting beat up north
jersey north jersey yeah you know jersey
you know all on my own stupidity
one time i got uh beat up in the city
one time we got chased trying to get
drugs or something
but never like uh
we didn't start trouble one time i got
beat up with this guy i was trying to
bait
we would mug these [ __ ] pedophiles
and [ __ ]
up in north jersey
so
you were mugging pedophiles mugging [ __ ]
that's justice
no these guys were like guys that were
drinking in the city and they get drunk
and they wanted a guy to suck that dick
so they'd take the [ __ ] uh west side
highway and come over to northern new
jersey and we'd hang out by a park and
we had a dude who looked kind of
handsome we'd take his shirt off
and he'd be the bait
and we'd wait by a [ __ ] tree you know
what i'm saying
what would he do before a car would he
just be like he would just be standing
on the corner whistling
and the car would pull up and then he'd
do a u-turn
and then he'd do another turn and on
that one he'd look at you like
and you look back
and also he'd pull up and go excuse me
do you know how to get to 48 8
29th street and the guy's like no you're
on
a [ __ ] 200th street you're far away
uh are you looking for a ride or you
lost
and almost it would be perfect
you would i saw this
at 17 16. so what then you guys are
running up on the dude in the car no no
then my body would go
so what do you want to do
you know what you want to do
i don't know what you want to do i don't
pull a car over let's talk about it
and the guy would get out of the car
because your [ __ ] thing is weak here
you are this guy's like 25 26 he's
probably married got a kid
but he's been wanting to get his dick
sucked for years
he's his father's italian he could never
get his dick sucked with his father's
still alive
oh he won't get none of that he was on
the way back from the funeral or
something there's a lot of guys like
that but you could tell they want to
suck a dick but
they got too deep they fell into the
american dream and now they can't tell
nobody they want to suck a dick that
dude they got kids they got a wife
but when you see him you're like that
dude's a dick sucker we don't have that
one friend in a circle that you look at
and you go you know what i know one that
if i get real drunk
i could talk this guy in the second my
dick one night at four in the morning
with nobody's watching and [ __ ]
hysterical it really is [ __ ] crazy
how
i don't even know what we're talking
about you mugging the pedophile so they
would they'd get out of the car
and they would come up to my friend and
my friend would walk with them
and i never climbed one of the trees i'm
never a tree climb i'd hide behind a
tree and [ __ ]
and he'd take him under the tree where
my buddy would be
up there like [ __ ] rambo trying to
fall off the tree
and also my friend would go you want me
to suck your dick yeah i pull you
where's the money
and the guy would take the 50 out
and if he had like more cash on him he'd
go take down your pants the guy would
take his dick out as my friend would put
one knee down he'd come right up and
kick the guy in the balls
the guy would drop and then the guy in
the tree would drop on him with a karate
chop
and awesome eight of us would charge him
with bayonets and
he's so excited and he just turned so
bad
oh my god
he want a [ __ ] nightmare
and for the record
i probably did it six times to like
[ __ ] like two of them like chubby
tuck truck drivers like none of these
guys were really gay these guys were not
gay at all they were just confused guys
i saw that in early and i saw i would go
down how the u-turn
the whole thing would play out we'd be
sitting there for three four hours but
there was a crew of guys in north bergen
that had become professionals at it
like this is jerk like we were talking
about things that happened in jersey
when i was growing up
there was
my town is really big how big is
watching how big was your grand i'm from
greenbrook greenbrook um that's like
yeah that's right near north plainfield
um bridgewater all right
right there right there now how far is
north plain feel from [ __ ]
playing field right next to it right now
yes
well that was that playing field was bad
yeah playing play feels tough no playing
fields you know
yeah those they're tough they're it's a
tough spot
north playing field jesus [ __ ] christ
i haven't heard those words in years i
grew up playing football with all those
kids did you yeah
group group three or group four um in
high school
uh we're group four i watch on i watch
on i was captain football team my senior
year
so you guys group four and you guys were
white
yeah oh watching hill super white that's
all
that means you play the big black
[ __ ] from group four because
group four my district is we had to play
you know east orange yeah yeah bayonne
and jersey city you know now we didn't
play hudson catholic in basketball we
had to play saint anthony's
okay because they're group four you're
in north bergen i was i went to north
bergen which is
encountered yeah
so we were group four but that's right
because it's like group four
section eight that means they got 90
[ __ ] eights what are the groups mean
the size of the size of the school so we
had a 1500 graduating class my high
school in 1982 so we were group four
yeah we were like 2 000 something yeah
how many
no yeah yeah yeah six hundred of grades
that's that's like two thousand jesus i
was like three hundred degree
yeah so we were group four we were group
four up which is hoboken yeah hoboken
union hill memorials group four
and we play union we play union we play
hackensack
the ghosts playing field playing field
and [ __ ] now who plays like neptune new
jersey i don't know
that's down the shore
where is [ __ ]
man
okay let me tell you something that was
the scariest thing i ever saw in 1980 it
was neptune new jersey biddy basketball
1980 it was [ __ ] odd [ __ ]
it was real they say the rumor that
neptune is where joe tyson's from
isn't joking
he's from down there and so is jack
nicholson
from matt right madison neptune whatever
supposedly neptune but maniswan claimed
him and [ __ ]
see because he didn't want to let people
know he was from neptune new jersey joe
thought he's been climbing claims new
brunswick and where where where yeah
maybe
i may be wrong way to go to high school
watch okay
let's see let's see here let's see
mr [ __ ] new brunswick
unless you want my stomping ground yeah
unless he went to new brunswick high
he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
watch sell the river high when i tell
you how far is that
how far is that
how far south river yeah see down the
[ __ ] shore [ __ ] don't lie to me
[ __ ]
no wonder laurence taylor broke your
legs
told you
he claims yeah they claim that [ __ ]
later
because the south river is that is that
right past uh like near highland park
like right past i have no idea
the only thing i'll say is if it could
be just the hospital he was born that
was in new brunswick yeah that's what it
is that's why i said yeah what high
school
it's gonna say they're from whatever but
where'd they grow up
yeah they said when they say south river
that means people are dying yeah he was
raised in southern that's what south
river means [ __ ] are dying okay
there's a river there
something's going on a little turbo in
the [ __ ] south river and [ __ ] right
oh my god
that's the truth that's when they put us
south river that whole [ __ ] area
there by whatever the woods is that
where they got stuck in the woods in the
in the sopranos the russians that's the
pine as a pine barrel that's the pine
barrens that's down the shore that's
[ __ ] crazy
down the shores where you guys see
people get kicked in the teeth
madison
that's why i see i've seen some
listen it's 1982
we rent the [ __ ] house
seaside
seaside and then little bits you could
get little hotels in those days which
had been there since 1940.
those things were older than dick but on
the seaside seaside park border
when i was in high school there was a
[ __ ] guy
that food
he had
sad bread hot
dogs with the chili and the buns no he
had the the onions and the sauerkraut
and the whole thing but he was italian
he made his own chili with a little kick
to it
yeah oh my [ __ ] god
i would give a hand for that [ __ ]
chili right now
he would get you for
10 hot no he would give you 12 hot dogs
for 20 bucks when we were in high school
we'd smoke a [ __ ] joint and we each
go in on that and tip the [ __ ]
and he had like sodas and something else
everybody down the shore at some
different angle man the burger king
where's [ __ ] see you guys are too
young there was a club called montego
bay
i wonder where see mana squan has
the biggest bar in the in
jersey the
the whatever the [ __ ] what is it
no
the biggest bar down the jersey shore is
in manasquan it's called the
osprey
the osprey has been there since jesus
chicago dog that's how long my high
school football coaches
worked security at the [ __ ] osprey
that's how old that [ __ ] place is
so
wherever belmar
belmore
belmore that burger king in belmore let
me drop it on you was the only burger
king in new jersey when i was in high
school that served sweet iced tea in the
summer that [ __ ] was hopping
jack you understand me
[ __ ] iced tea with lemon in it
we live for that [ __ ] in jersey i
remember going down this show i was
telling some guys a story the other day
about
now for me to live where i live
to go down the shore i heard on a friday
night it really is three or four hours
is that true i don't know you don't live
for what to go
uh if you go late
you can make in two
but yeah it could be three hours for
sure from where you're coming from yeah
you're at the top you're probably new
york when i was a kid it used to be 45
[ __ ] minutes ah no way oh my god i
wish we used when i was in high school i
was so fortunate we had buddies that
worked at ups and saddlebrook
all right and they work from 11 to 2
when they got out of two but i had this
other friend named rob merlo and his dad
had a restaurant in paramus called
mandos
so he would pay us each 25 bucks and all
you could eat if we would go back to his
bar at one in the morning and we cleaned
the bar and then we worked for stinky
and the other guy to get out of work at
[ __ ] ups and we all drive down the
seaside together okay we weren't [ __ ]
high school guy
50 bucks
unbelievable kids won't do this [ __ ]
today they're too busy on their [ __ ]
computers
analyzing things
[Music]
take a chance columbus did
so [ __ ] um
we would go back to this restaurant i'm
gonna make he go in the office and his
dad had lobster tails when we started
eating those [ __ ] laps the tails
mickey like we owned the joint and he
would come back and you know what
happened to the lobster tails we'd go
through 20 lobster tails i said you
could eat anything not just the lobster
tails we'd eat the [ __ ] lobster tails
we'd get [ __ ] hammered you know and
then get in the car and drive down the
shore we wouldn't pay tolls
okay that's almost 45 minutes you're
doing 90. no no i'm i'm still with that
or
or
the guy in the passenger seat would hook
shot a quarter over if it made it it
made it
[ __ ] if it dies
really crazy [ __ ] man that you know like
i told you guys before when you tell
people that you ran a toll if you tell
normal people
they'll look at you and go why it's a
corner what kind of that being i don't
have time to stop and roll down my
window and aim and put oh my god fly
now they got that [ __ ] thing though
so ping the quick flight and then that
[ __ ] at the end of the month
you're gonna build for 2 000. you're
done if i listen i get a bill for 2 000
i'm in the bronx getting [ __ ] bread
20 to go to the [ __ ] broncos yep
they they tore all the uh toll booths
down in massachusetts it's crazy it's
all digital now
can you imagine no
that used to be like a bunch of
jobs listen bro we're living in
communist times without even knowing it
they know exactly where all five of us
are right now with our phones
and our own little stupidity
we logged in on facebook
everybody knows where we are
everybody knows what that's the craziest
one to me checking in
especially if if you're on vacation
i don't want anyone to know i'm on
vacation that my my buddy just got his
door kicked in he i flew him out to uh
to cali with me for the fight
i fly like my boys out so out there with
me all week uh the first day he's gone
his door gets kicked in he's an
allentown pa
or no easton pa eastern door gets kicked
in tv stolen that's got to be like
someone who who you know right up on
facebook probably without your instagram
or something yeah seeing that yeah oh he
just got out of the couch drinking his
[ __ ] yeah they're kicking your [ __ ]
door now as if you drive back cocktail
yeah i'd go in your house cook eggs
do laundry
sniff your mom's underwear
and then take the piano in 18 [ __ ]
hours are you [ __ ] kidding me
dog i used to work construction
on the fir i like i moved to snowmass
in april of 83 and i had a couple jobs
but i wanted a job in snowmass i didn't
want to go off the hill
if you go to colorado
sometimes you have to it would take me
like and it wouldn't be a pain he has to
go downhill as they called it down
valley it was next to aspen snowmass
village but i got a job and these
[ __ ] i was walking one day and i'm
talking to this dude
and i asked him what he was doing he was
remodeling these condos but this is a
[ __ ] filthy rich people
that would buy a condo in aspen in
snowmass
but they would live in boston per se
but they might visit or they wouldn't
visit and they leave their skis in their
polls the whole thing we're working on
these things we had to have the doors
open i would just go into houses and
watch tv and put my feet up and [ __ ]
the whole eight weeks i was on the
[ __ ] job every day i was in a
different house watching tv eating their
[ __ ] crackers and [ __ ] they didn't
have nothing good in there sometimes
they had a soda who the [ __ ] who the
[ __ ] has that much money
what about them popping in on you like
how can you enjoy watching that tv
because i was doing construction that i
had okay you had it out i was taking a
break no no no
i wanted to know what happened something
happened in san francisco my uncle lives
there in the earthquake okay oh it's
okay there's always a [ __ ] i'm not
gonna just sit in your house like an
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying
but i knew these people wouldn't come
back you know i knew the daily report
the guy with the guy that i was doing
construction was telling me
these people ain't coming back go into
that guys and turn the power in there
plug the this and there plug that in
that uh condo there was only it was like
four condos or five condos were working
and it was the weirdest shape
it's just the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
knows what's up lee you got something on
your mind i would just always be
like that like that i think would be the
way to do it now if you were going to be
a robber would you you'd have to like go
on social media that's what i said like
that yeah but you could package that you
can't be a robber no more because you
seven out of ten people got a camera
yeah
everybody's got a camera and you know
what you got a mask on you can [ __ ]
dress up like nixon and don't give a
[ __ ]
they'll get you one where they can
follow you back
they got something
and then you have your phone on you they
catch you one way or another the gps in
your car you made a phone call from your
car and they hit a satellite that hit
the there's always a by the way now run
a red light they take a picture we gotta
do smoke and joint wants csi you won't
even cross the street when the hand is
up
they got you they [ __ ] got you they
really got you man
and you know you think about what
communism is is being watched not told
what to think but kind of
we're being we're watched
well every time you lift that [ __ ]
computer
and you type in your stupidity you know
i want to see a chick eat a [ __ ]
tennis ball with a finger in her [ __ ]
that goes right to the government look
at this momo right also some guy gets a
beep and there you are your camera turns
on there you are whacking off of this
[ __ ] circle on the camera and they
got you on you don't think they're
watching you when you're whacking off on
the computer
what do you think the what do you think
happens they watch everything
they watch everything man
but anyway
who gives a [ __ ] well i mean we're all
dead already they all have our passwords
they all have everything they were dead
are you do you have to worry about that
mickey like even from uh like a ufc
state like are you worried about going
out to a club and someone instigating
something then you get in trouble with
tmz or anything like that um nah i'm not
not really i never looked for i never
looked for fights
but you know if if something if
something happened like that
yeah i'd hit him i'd get out of there
quick
or not not even that maybe maybe like i
don't know
a girl or whatever like a twitter tirade
against someone whatever it may be do
you do you have to think and like calm
down or because it like it's i'm always
surprised that all these athletes are
even allowed to have social media
whenever someone has a crazy social
media thing happened i'm like i don't
get it
yeah it's tough man social media it's a
weird thing
you know you're you're a young guy ain't
stopping
i mean it's not like you're out [ __ ]
boozing or whatever but here's a funny
thing
in today's [ __ ] world with what you
got going on you have to kind of live in
a bubble
for you to achieve your dream man you
gotta be smart
listen uh
shit's not gonna happen to you when you
go
before your boys for a drink but we're
from jersey
there's always one [ __ ] knucklehead
bro
and it's that knucklehead you want me to
tell you what one day you're gonna hear
amen
remember when we were 13 on pee wee's
remember i [ __ ] tackled you that day
and you're like what are you talking
about
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
and he'll come at you like what what
what you're like what are you and all
you want to do is go in there and get a
soda your little pizza joint there's
always one of those morons where we're
from that you know it's not when you go
out to a club it's
it's always with uh you know that one
drunk dude dog you ain't dick you have
mr ufc
when we were 12. remember that i [ __ ]
tackled you [ __ ]
what are you talking about
i packed with you and you cried
you ain't [ __ ] mr ufc
is it fun going back home like do people
freak out
um dude i mean i haven't been home since
the last one but after the cm punk one
everyone i i'm just oh you that guy who
beat up cm punk
everyone's like like a gas station
across the street oh yeah i'm that guy
who beat up cm punk
i got anybody come up here and go bro
you beat up cm punk
beat me up punk i'll [ __ ] you nah
nah soon soon yeah i'm waiting for [ __ ]
and you have to giggle yeah like a guy
like you like giggles i have guys come
up and be like dude i was rooting for cm
punk i'm like oh hi sorry buddy sorry to
do it to you
why would you go up to something in
today's world just shut your [ __ ] i
was raised you don't want to shut your
[ __ ] people crazy people are really
you must get you must get a lot of
people saying dumb [ __ ]
you know what when people drink at
comedy shows after the shows they get
kind of crazy but i write it off man
i write it off in a weird way like
they're drinking i know they ate an
edible
they probably started drinking at four
you have to judge the circumstances this
isn't a big city you know
there's always something you know i just
yeah
i understand that at this point and
there's always a lot of people there so
there's always a line so they're always
moving you know yeah
who the [ __ ] knows man
it was uh
we were speaking about before the show
about like
how like not knowing how to like how i
get like really when i get really stoned
how i can like still manage but i like
i'm still [ __ ] up but joey you can
really manage
what i was thinking about was
isn't it it's kind of like when people
get in the fight and they like they kind
of go crazy like i've never been in a
fight i think if i got punched
i think i i wouldn't know what to do
do you think it's kind of comparable to
like you know if you got pun like you
kind of reacting and and knowing how to
handle yourself
what do you mean like we were talking
about how like for me
i have i've built up a tolerance to weed
in a way in a small way
do you think you've built up a tolerance
to getting punched and what like it
doesn't shock you i don't know
in a [ __ ] up way
i see what you're saying
not pro no one's like punching me like
just walking down the street though you
know i mean right out there
that you mean you mean out no i mean
even in the ufc
uh yeah i guess you get you get a little
desensitized to it
not your first time getting hit yeah but
you've been getting hit
the [ __ ] yeah but yeah but you know
you're getting if you were going into a
cage to get in a fight you'd be like i
know i'm probably gonna get hit you know
what i mean right you probably know that
but
i mean finding cm
having fought cm punk did you do you
think he was shocked
do you think he was like
unprepared oh yeah man yeah maybe i
don't think anyone hit no i don't think
anyone hit him the way i hit him
right so yeah that probably opened his
eyes a little bit but you've got the
adrenaline and all that stuff going
i'm saying no no i'm not i who knows
that could be way too stoned but it just
you're way too [ __ ] stoned trust me
you're trying to confuse the guy you're
worse than my wife my wife tonight
ordered something
and the wrong order got there
and she's like call them up and i'm
going to call them my nose and she goes
oh
i think i'm [ __ ] up and i know you did
because you talk too much
you confuse them
you confuse yourself out of the [ __ ]
game
two weeks ago the baby wants to go to
mcdonald's
i hate [ __ ] mcdonald's but i go to
mcdonald's as a joke
as a joke a month before that i said to
her wow
that mcrib don't look too bad listen i
wouldn't need to [ __ ] make rib
if he gave me a thousand dollars it
looks good and i want to eat that
[ __ ] thing but i know i'm gonna
[ __ ] die if i eat that thing
we go up to the counter the dude barely
speaks english
i order the baby the six piece mcnugget
my wife wants to [ __ ] quarter pound
the you know what i'll take a quarter
pound and she goes i know you're
thinking about the [ __ ] the whatever
i don't say nothing next thing you know
there's a [ __ ] big rib there because
the dude don't [ __ ] hablo
and she just brings [ __ ] up and then she
she confuses herself sometimes i told
her this is what happens when you
[ __ ] bring that [ __ ] up tonight she
[ __ ] up the order again and now that's
lee
i don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
saying what happens if you get hit
if he's been fighting how long you been
fighting for eight years eight years
yeah how many times you get hit in the
head already
i don't know okay all right have you had
a broken nose no all right god bless
your [ __ ] soul
yeah
yeah but he's been hitley the way you
have experience in coming in here
exactly the way you have experience how
to download the podcast and how to
navigate a podcast if it gets lost
unlike you and myself
i [ __ ]
if you pass my garden land on top of me
and grab my shoulder i see [ __ ] stars
i don't even need to get hit anymore you
understand me he has already built that
tolerance exactly yeah you know that's
why the first time i saw when brock
lesnar fought
that guy aubrey
no velasquez
dude the white dude from denver that
hits hard are you caring
no that's threatening to come back
oh
big muscle shane carlin shane conway one
of the first things i noticed when he
fought shane khan when shane carlin
popped him
and [ __ ] if you see he covered his
face
i could tell right there he had never
been punched in the [ __ ] face before
there are big dudes like that they don't
get hit because they're so big people
don't wanna no i got an email three or
four days later from somebody saying
don't you know that
when you train with him you're not
allowed to hit him in the face
why do that then why do this this is a
game where you get you it the number one
thing is recovering
when i was [ __ ] six i got hit in the
head with a flashlight it took me 18
years to recover fighting rainfall as i
was saying
when i was 24 when that woke up what
happened
abcd i got hit in the [ __ ] head with
a flashlight in central park the true
story
it took me a day and a half to recover
from the shock it was the first time my
life virginity had been broken
because
you know
for you to get in a [ __ ] ring
for you to get up one day or you know
what
i think i'm gonna become a [ __ ]
fighter something must have happened you
must have bitch-slapped the [ __ ]
one day after a football game or
thrown somebody up against the wall
there was this one certain guy that
everybody thought that was a badass you
just tormented his [ __ ] life you
understand me so one day you realize you
want to do this
you go in there the dude trains you for
a few weeks then come spa thursday
whatever you go in there the guy looks
like [ __ ] me and heat
and all of a sudden next thing now your
nose is broken your ear is huge your
stomach hurts you're bleeding from
everywhere
the guy that comes back the next day
yeah
yeah that's it
that's the guy right there that's it
this guy's gonna tell you he broke a rib
it's floating i used to spar five days a
week at ama fight club you know i am if
i could write mike constantino no jim
and dan miller where is it oh no new
jersey in jersey when whippany whippany
now how far is whipley from your house
20 20 minutes 20 25 yeah wow yeah
yeah damn
yeah that's where that's where like i
cut my teeth training with those guys
jim dan miller
uh charlie brennaman
that's a great jiu jitsu base right
there yeah we use and i i used to like i
didn't grow up fighting that much i
gained a couple of scraps of kid but
yeah i was born five days a week then
just like it was which is way too much
but i was you know i was like i was like
20 just loving it just having fun
for mma sparring
uh yeah and sometimes just like you know
kickboxing yeah uh yeah not not every
day like i do like that i do the muay
thai sparring
one day and then yeah three three days a
week i do the pro practices where i was
yeah we were spawning but you just was
solid huh yeah yeah like a
[ __ ] you know can't take that
away from you tarzan
jesus christ
where else do you train uh gracie new
jersey that's where my jiu jitsu got and
where's that it's in uh clinton
it's out west right off like that exit
17 off 78.
oh boy you're way left there yeah it's
west i know clifton clifton that's north
yeah that's north that's my route 3.
yeah there used to be a driving theater
there that's why i first saw kung fu
movies
yeah but clifton
and that's the israeli guy that's in
clinton
that's the israeli israeli guy yeah
david
badass oh i could just
a [ __ ] jiu jitsu those [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] around with krav maga
weapons
no you [ __ ] get him in an armbar he
still has a flying star in this game
what the [ __ ] happened
i had a flying star in my gate that's
[Music]
right there
as you're taking that arm back yeah the
armbar you like watch my hip be really
what happened i don't know
yeah that's uh that's a different
[ __ ] level jungle type
yeah [ __ ] they add some of that [ __ ] to
it lee how you feeling over there oh my
god i'm feeling i'm going through
changes tonight
those chalk whatever what are those
called space bars
moon bars oh my god
i have to not breathe
that's my trick i just i just don't
breathe out of my nose and that's why i
make noises because it's just
as soon as it hits the back of my throat
it's crazy see everything's going to be
all right we working on that
what's the story you want to fight in
brooklyn
um
that's that's a nice one that's a nice
card
maybe 11. it's quick that'd be a quick
turnaround i gotta yeah see i got the
stitches i got eight stitches i um i got
20 i got 21
uh three weeks before cm punk i had to
hide that
and then the doctor's like you gotta
give it six months for the collagen i
was like [ __ ] that i'm fighting and then
i took this other quick fight
so this is the things i i got i should
probably give it a little time yeah
brooklyn's quick turnaround
dude i gotta show actually you probably
you probably faint if i showed you the
picture i will show you that yeah i
don't want to see that i'm just thinking
i'm just talking about i see you change
a little bit yes
that's [ __ ] up that's the hardest part
that oh my god after you get cut or
something they just wipe that blood
right there i would tap i don't listen
enough is enough that made me feel good
when when i got cut in this fight i was
like oh i like this that warm blood on
your face it drives some people crazy
that's what it's supposed to be that's
that's when the party starts yeah that's
it that's it i just i just know there's
anything
knows what's that first blood
everything's all right you want to bit
slap me you want to kick me in the leg
that's all right i think i'm gonna do
nothing for nobody but once [ __ ]
sees he's bleeding that's when the party
is like now what
what now you [ __ ] what's this
and [ __ ]
watch you go ahead
what's up lisa why are you looking at me
oh [ __ ] the blow your head back
lay your head back if you're gonna
[ __ ] we're gonna eat it i thought
we're gonna eat another style of respect
for hanukkah this weekend absolutely
what the [ __ ] let's do this [ __ ] do this
[ __ ]
do this [ __ ] do this [ __ ] what do this
[ __ ]
look at your [ __ ] bad [ __ ]
representing jersey and [ __ ] all day you
don't go to other jiu jitsu places at
all you don't go to i've been on
manhattan the henzo's get some work
there's great guys there but uh like
technique wise i mean yeah david deeve
he's your man he's sharp he's like he's
like gonna be well with shows no his
shows man again [ __ ] show strangling
people man yeah all that
that was tremendous yeah
that was tremendous i just sat there but
i saw the countdown later that night i
remember like typing oh [ __ ] i did tape
it what happened till that day
i saw two little girls and
you like i'm starting to get this
picture here this could become [ __ ]
deadly
this is new jersey and [ __ ] now you
gotta go back
this summer and jump in that water that
water toughens jersey i go i will go
every weekend that's that's that's a
secret right that's what nobody's got i
was tanned for the cm punk fights i was
in the water every every weekend yeah
yeah all that new clear energy love it
and all that new jersey waste gets that
ocean oh they can't [ __ ] stop that
you know it's all over yeah you're like
[ __ ] spiderman they don't even know
it they don't even know
they have no [ __ ] idea that beach was
polluted with hypodermic beetles 20
years yeah dude i've been going there my
whole life my grandma
and my grandparents
owned a house in lbi right near the
beach so i go all summer that water
toughens you up like i'm oh [ __ ] they
don't even know they gotta check check
deep deep deep
into the cells and [ __ ] make up the
diabolic and yeah there's oil slicks in
there and
mafia bodies and [ __ ] everything
jimmy hoffa give me half a dust and the
whole [ __ ] deal and [ __ ]
jimmy
i like that one you should sell that on
your on your site
you make a killing
this is the part i don't like there's a
part where this is the part where
there's a part where your head just hums
and i could deal with the harmon and
hear you know the loud noises and the
[ __ ] yelling and i could deal with
all that
it's when i have to do something very
physical
then i turn my head real quick while i
laugh that's when i feel oh [ __ ] this
could get ugly so then i gotta start
breathing out of my nose
i gotta go back to the island the
serenity
i get the party started i'm back
how many years ago was that five four
years ago but it works for me [ __ ]
all right no i just love that you went
to like two sessions with her and you
just really use it why not
it was a buck twenty year session i got
to get that down to 50 a day you know
what i'm saying
that's what i give the [ __ ] animals
50 a day
50 cents a day i'm sorry yeah man it
calms me down it still works
oh you know you want me to say what's up
to you uh todd duffy
oh that's [ __ ] savage i'm doing his
uh his podcast tomorrow calling in the
fighters opinion now where is he he's in
santa cruz thought i was saying earlier
santa cruz
[ __ ] that's a good place yeah he's a
good dude he is a good dude he is a good
dude i haven't seen him when i do san
jose or something he shows up
and i bumped into him into a ufc where
is he fighting are you upset though uh
yeah yeah he's um i think he has
something coming up he was talking and
he's talking about talking to you about
auctioning off his co one of his corner
tickets
like one of the people to be in his
corner okay i don't know he'll talk to
you about it okay
yeah
auction office corner tickets wow
like someone could like go and walk out
with him to be in the back it's kind of
a cool idea it's a great idea i would
never want to be in somebody's corner
i'm the kiss of death
like if you put me strategically i could
yell and they give you a little
instructions different languages what's
that it's intense what's the question
like being in the corner like when like
i had a buddy my buddy algeria bully
fight recently all of a sudden it hits
you you get nervous like it's you can't
control it when it's you at least you
can control it
it's just him going in there
he choked it out 26 seconds so no
problem i could never go to one of your
fights no no because i got to know you
and i got to like you
i don't want to know nothing tell me
later yeah i could watch on tv but i
could never go see you my grandma
watched this one i told her not to i
tell her not to watch any of them
she watched this one she called me today
you know i watched
what did she say
she was like well i looked away when on
the parts i didn't like but
yeah dude she felt bad for cm punk after
she watched my last one so how could you
do that to him
yeah
it's not for them how good is that
feeling to have your family watch on tv
i have no family to watch me no mom and
no dad how great is it
that your family's still alive
to watch them on to watch on tv
oh yeah unfortunately what happened with
your family they all came out
yeah they all they all flew out
i see them stressing out all week
trying to keep them calm oh [ __ ]
i could never imagine having
a son going into the [ __ ] octagon and
[ __ ] and me going to the fight i could
never even imagine it
my head would blow up i'm not cut out
for that type of [ __ ]
i'm really not my head would blow up my
head goes somewhere else man at those
things
like one time i got to talk to anderson
silva and i got to talk to him again
and i went to a fight one time where he
got into trouble like i was ready to get
a gun
like i'm old school i get the [ __ ]
gun dog this is getting deep and i'm
like wait a second i'm in a [ __ ] ufc
fight just because i
just cause i don't don't mean i gotta
[ __ ] go in there like i get so i
don't go
i just
once somebody i like is on the card i
won't go to those fights
i'll watch him at the house but i'll get
up i'll go outside and smoke a joint
make believe i don't know nothing
then i'll come in he'll win and i go i
knew he was going to win i just can't
[ __ ] watch
i get too nervous i don't like that [ __ ]
yes rough
it's rough that's why i watch it like i
was watching the middle parents brother
i employed your parents yeah give them a
big hug when you get home oh i will yeah
they're cool [ __ ] yeah they
went to see you and they got balls of
steel
you would have loved my dad i'm
surprised you guys think you guys
probably crossed paths back in the day
did he go to bergen county jail
no no
he's uh
after my last fight his friends were up
telling me like dude your dad was he was
like the baddest guy in new jersey he
was like he's the toughest guy in new
jersey he and he was like he was a
football player like he tried out for
the giants it wasn't like a troublemaker
but he'd throw it down like they had
stories
wild stories what high school did he go
to watch him he went to no he went to
manalapan he went to st john vianney for
a little bit
beat like he like started he was
starting football and then he got in a
bunch of he got a couple fights with
like the seniors
and then he had he got like he had to
leave there went to manhattan
the only kids i remember when i was
growing up and down the shore pete
penuska from brick
okay
brick that's you right around there yeah
and brick and there was a kid craig
hayward
that just died recently he played the
nfl craig haywood ironhead
he was big out of like montclair some
no no no he was from somewhere else
but i'll tell you what man when i was
about
i got left back right not because i was
stupid
but because i fell in love with this
girl started dry humping it this is a
true story in the sixth grade in the
seventh grade so you got left back
and this is a [ __ ] up story like i
like basketball at that time i used to
go to karate every [ __ ] day
then bruce lee died and i kept going to
karate i went to karate university new
jersey
at this gushing room karate place and he
would check your report card
if you didn't get good grades she'd
still make you come in do the jumping
jacks and the push-ups but when he
taught you'd have to do your homework
and then he checked it after by the time
he had by the time he stopped teaching
you how to have your homework [ __ ]
done this is old school
the guy was like an ex-marine and [ __ ]
he didn't want to go to those classes
but i liked what he did
i liked what he did and i was okay but
when i started dry humping that girl i
stopped going to class well i go to
karate class when you drive up and say
i'm saying and we weren't even having
sex and i was already [ __ ] in love
with it yeah like it was driving me
[ __ ] bananas so i got left back
i just had to start from the seventh
grade she wouldn't let me dry humper no
more because i got left back once you
get left back you can't drive home
somebody ain't gonna drive this [ __ ]
loser
[ __ ]
one night man i'm watching
the ncaa [ __ ] finals
i swear to god i'm just sitting there i
don't know nothing about nothing
i'm into basketball i'm interested in
basketball
i can [ __ ] rebound
i could i could jump you know i
i'm not a great shooter but whatever and
i'm watching this [ __ ] basketball
game
and they're announcing the starting
this is national
[ __ ] tv
and they're announcing the starting five
players from north carolina you know
what it's like to
go to north carolina that's like [ __ ]
being a ufc fighter
yeah i'm saying and submitting a
[ __ ] on national television
that's what it's like to go to north
carolina where
that was the basketball that was the top
north carolina played marquette on
national television for the national
championship
this other team's coach was retiring
that night but [ __ ] north carolina
was on a [ __ ] roll
but somebody had gotten hurt in north
carolina there was an adjustment
i'll never forget that they they
announced the the senator and then
the the two guards and then the forward
and the forward when they said he was
from jersey city new jersey my [ __ ]
head blew up i was like what the [ __ ]
did he just say the last time they
started talking about this kid they're
like this kid is a savage and i'm like a
savage from new jersey a savage and then
like he
the player before him got hurt
on saturday and he went in there into
the final four and scored 31
[ __ ] points as a sixth man
nobody's ever done that as a sixth man
now he they just said [ __ ] it start him
in the finals and he was just a skinny
[ __ ] white kid and you know
he's there's 10 dudes on the [ __ ]
thing in those days and there was only
one white dude it was this dude battling
it out and he still got like 14 points
and like eight rebounds but i thought i
was like [ __ ] it if some kid from jersey
said he could do it on national tv we
got to figure something out here man
this kid was and then in reports came
out he's still around michael coren
he's an announcer somewhere for tnt
somewhere but i'll never forget that
moment like that made me so [ __ ]
happy and i didn't even know i can't
imagine what your [ __ ] family feels
like you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah
it's gotta be crazy you're gonna go home
there's a parade and watch
how did your jiu-jitsu school feel
because that that would have been like
especially since you submitted
i think all three yeah yeah so you
submitted all the way late like they
must get pissed if you do with anything
wrong like have any have any of your
coaches been like nah that was good but
i couldn't let them down yeah the uh the
technique was a little you should put
the foot here yeah
yeah nah yeah they're they're happy it's
a team win man but like when i win
that's all of us when you know someone
else from team wins team effort
you got some jersey pride
hell yeah you ready to rock and roll
dude you gotta tell one of the jersey
stories that the world isn't ready for
on the ones you've been holding back
for the people let them know what's up
i have no idea i don't even think that
dark anymore
i have a child now i've erased all those
dark
memories every once in a while my body
twitches
in the middle of the night i'm like oh
lord please help me
don't let those memories come back to me
at all
they're [ __ ] hysterical i don't
you know man i don't know
i don't know there's a lot of sad story
there's just [ __ ] funny stuff i don't
even know anymore
who the hell knows man
i forgot to go on some of these podcasts
three weeks ago
like that's how bad
i was so busy i forgot like who the [ __ ]
knows about
dark deep stories anymore
jesus christ and tonight i'm [ __ ] up
let me tell you something that that
transmission fluid
if you hit a number
huh did a number on you yeah that
transmission flow [ __ ] you up yeah i
could barely think talk you really think
it's the transmission fluid i think it's
that job oh the chocolation to murky
water is also it's like a
it's like a [ __ ]
boat what do you do what do we do in
jersey with the water slide we always
know a friend that takes us on the boat
we water ski
waters oh what's that called people do
it down the shore come on guys come on
bill what the [ __ ] what is it
not tubing it's something else
what is it wakeboarding
no it's the ski water skiing
water skiing water skiing you know i
remember going with stalin on the rogan
podcast we used to go down the shore and
um before you went over the bridge to
seaside you dropped cages
yeah you dropped cages into the [ __ ]
ocean and on the way home you came back
and there were crabs in there and you go
home and my friends would make an
italian red sauce with the [ __ ] crab
those are my memories from jersey though
that's all that's [ __ ] craziness
there what do you eat a lot of in jersey
ah
everything you live with at home yeah
i'm i'm clean though i eat pretty clean
do you yeah no chinese
uh sometimes
why you got a recommendation no you died
i'm watching i don't know nobody down
there yeah
i don't know nobody yeah
how fun i don't even know
how to get the watch i got some good
sushi over there it's like a sushi spot
there's one good really good place
mr pies
japanese have taken home with new jersey
they got good [ __ ] sushi oh yeah in
new jersey
what are you laughing molly
i just like the image of japanese taking
over new jersey
do you remember
the japanese were killing the dolphins
huh
do you remember i don't you don't you
don't watch south park but in south park
they were coming in and killing dolphins
randomly so that's just my image
but in new jersey
you could get good sushi in jersey
yeah
yeah in fort lee new jersey it's i think
it's the number one
we're number two
highly asian population in the country
it was kind of immense in the 80s
it just took off i don't you know
got good sushi in fort lee jack yeah
well they got good food everywhere in
new jersey that's the that's the great
thing about jersey is always
a diner
oh yeah that's the best diamonds are the
best
there's a lot of them too
i had to meet somebody to eat today and
i went to we went to stout
and uh we had the fries and
the burger and uh
tremendous [ __ ] burger you know great
fries
but those fries need some [ __ ] gravy
and they put the mozzarella on them yeah
and they're skinny fries and they cheese
them up pretty good but they need a
little gravy on to take you back that
little cheeseburger deluxe
eleven o'clock you have before you go
home
those little steak fries you go home
that's like a [ __ ] oh a sleeping pill
you sleep like a baby under that blanket
little cheeseburger deluxe
dog the other night i saw the longest
line ever
for in-n-out burger
i have ever seen
in the history that i have lived here
even longer than hollywood hollywood
line get some long i mean guys
some [ __ ] long lines up that street
wouldn't mean like three or four cars
this was
way past the office
this was a block south past the office
that's how long we've been already
focused on lancashire
it was [ __ ] crazy on sunday night
i was like who would wait in that type
of line for a cheeseburger
what animal would wait on that type of
line it kind of makes me want to time it
but then i'd have to wait there and time
it
and you might as well shoot yourself you
can't wait there
unless you bring a cheeseburger with you
makes fast food slow
there was a line today at the
jack in the box right next to where i
live it was like
at lunch time like down the street i was
like what's happened i never got it for
lunch
yeah she did
a couple times but mostly for dinner
what should we hit for dinner out here
one tonight
you haven't had dinner yet no we're
gonna eat you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] no you're gonna go to sunset
and you're gonna go to a place named
that's perfect we're going to a comedy
store anyway yeah
if you want to go to the sunset if
you're going to go to sunset
this place is uh
what time is it
9 40. i can't call the house
my wife well do you want to what about
sushi dan
i don't want them to spend 2 000 [ __ ]
dollars okay for [ __ ] uh i don't know
any place that they could go to sushi
that would just be neutral
so
what i would recommend is that israeli
place on sunset you're going to get a
nice piece of salmon okay with mashed
potatoes but i don't know the [ __ ]
name aroma aroma there you go
bam and you go right from aroma
to the comedy store what else is close
to the comedy store
the taco place on the corner
uh what else
not mad at tacos mcdonald's
[ __ ] that
uh the sandwich place by the laugh
factory
what's that that ralph you found ants in
the sandwiches
no
i'll steer clear so your best bet
for the bang is that aroma
nice little piece of salmon
see what's on the menu you read the menu
damn nice but yeah
look at he's already get the menu you
guys aren't used to lee has a menu for
everything
he's got 10 apps
we don't [ __ ] around no i don't have the
internet he's got 10 apps plus he's got
yelp control
plus he's got i spy network the only
shitty thing is you have to paint a park
there's always a by the way lee just
what's the menu i'm looking
you're on sunset what do you think is
going to happen
you want a [ __ ] up here too though
what do you mean it's up here
i had to
valid i had to get a uh validation to go
to starbucks
in uh studio city
okay here we go
i have no idea what he's talking about
you know there's a one um like cold
water or something somewhere around
there that has like you have to get you
have to get like a ticket from a machine
okay they have a bunch of sandwiches do
you want to read the sandwiches what's
the location let's get the sandwiches
what's location
um not to go there sorry
it's like sunset in hollywood yeah it's
sunset in hollywood yeah yeah yeah 70 70
73 73 sunset yeah that makes sense
got a comedy store is 8235 or 8253 or
something like that
so this is right before the guitar
center
if you hit the guitar center you went
too far you valet park in there because
the park is a [ __ ] there's
clubs it's goddamn [ __ ] tuesday night
and these savages are out and you park
in there you go in there
there was like three things i would get
in there that was fantastic but
they used to give you this bread like a
grape bread with raisins in it
this is
when you put olive oil on it [ __ ]
tremendous tastes like grapes
[ __ ] tremendous
i don't know how it is now yeah i could
beat now because i i was kind of oh no
no no no you go to toy you like thai
food right yeah
there you go toy what about what about
the italian place in hollywood are you
taking notes out of their business
they're from new jersey i'm gonna
embarrass them okay
i'm gonna embarrass them and take them
to some [ __ ] italian place they're
from jersey what they have on their
corner
is better whatever [ __ ] they're gonna
get here
what they have on that corner
is better than they should here i
wouldn't recommend these two savages
pizza
or sandwiches did you see what he said i
don't need no [ __ ] sandwiches
down the block from him with blindfolds
on
he'd get the best [ __ ] sandwich
that would kill any [ __ ] sound well
there's a place in santa monica they got
that they got the jersey bread no you
[ __ ] don't
no you don't if i drive to santa monica
i hate that jersey bread i'm gonna be
[ __ ] pissed off great jersey bread
you should you got you two should go to
jersey mikes
we got that in jersey too
that's the embarrassment to a guy like
me yeah i can't understand how
jersey mike's after like a week somebody
don't go and they go listen
this should rain is up [ __ ] all right
the sure
i tolerated it for a week
i thought you'd go away but there's a
bunch of [ __ ] idiots that have no
self-respect for themselves
no self-respect for themselves
okay
no self-respect for themselves i forget
the guy's [ __ ] name and i'm to be too
late to call my friend
when i lived on 85th street and grand
if you walk to the corner
left up the hill there was a guy in
there he didn't have a full grocery
store but he always had thulman's
baloney
doom and sam
and that [ __ ] uh sliced american
cheese that he sliced fresh and [ __ ] he
got shot three times one time he got
robbed like eighty dollars the next day
that [ __ ] was dead tip top
conditions
three bullets three bullets but the
funny thing is he made sandwiches i was
gonna say he's so big
if you were like eight and you brought
enough from your mother you give you a
gallon of vodka he was one of those
dudes
if you came out my mother said to give
you this
and give you this 20 bill he'd give you
a gallon of vodka a carton of cigarettes
and a book of messes tell your mother i
love her he was one of those [ __ ]
dudes or he put it on a tab i had a tab
with him
brilliant this guy worked all his life
there guess what happens
jersey mike comes along
and opens up down the corner and now
these [ __ ] same people who've been
buying great coat cuts
great white bread from this guy go down
the corner because they have a foot long
for 6.95 or whatever the [ __ ]
bro they
have and i have nothing against these
restaurants i get it they have a
whatever what's an olive
olive garden on times square
yeah what does that tell you yeah
who would [ __ ] walk in there it's
like when you see the sabaro and yeah in
new york you're like are you crazy why
would you go to sabaro what type of
animal
what type of [ __ ] [ __ ] are you
and you know and again
you know they have all these hey kkks
and all these things why don't like
[ __ ]
22 angry white guys shave their heads
and just start going to these places
listen
it was okay
again olive garden gotta go this is new
we're not having it no
listen first the [ __ ]
italians can make it then we'll let a
couple of greeks make italian food and a
couple of [ __ ] uh
mexicans make and what's the other ones
that are half italians russians no
because they're making it too no
albanians
they own half of new jersey yeah bam
there you go they don't have yeah
they're running
deep yeah they will grow a mustache and
tell you they're in town
they don't give a [ __ ] one of the best
italian restaurants in jersey is
albanian owned uh i forget what the
girl's name is she's a radio dj so
there's there's a there's a real good
one uh my i have uh my close cousins are
in harrington park in bergen county
um they got a restaurant right near
there a good italian place i couldn't
tell the name though
there's so many
that's what i miss but when i go home i
know there's but there's still this
place where i grew up named roma
oh my god the best [ __ ] stromboli in
the world
and there were a few places that mesa
shrimp parmesan
are you kidding me or what
how come you didn't take me there
because i took you for chinese the
important things
you could eat but it doesn't matter
what's your chinese dish
i would never take you for pizza
anywhere anywhere ever again because
you'll still come back and go up to that
[ __ ] place revolt
whatever the [ __ ] name of it
and get stand online to eat [ __ ]
manufactured outside the us doe
that doe comes in ship from like
bulgaria or something like that
for everyone
he doesn't like pizza raft
yeah pizza what pizza right man one of
those places where you go and you can
like it's like the chipotle of pizzas
gotcha
yeah he doesn't like that
it it's not that i don't like it it's
the same reason
why i don't like [ __ ]
olive garden i don't like [ __ ] jersey
mics the same reason because you're
going in there with a half-loaded gun
and you're cutting into the
[ __ ] that are really doing the
job
sure it's a half-loaded gun
and these are the real deal no
so these idiots go in there and for two
dollars left and that's why
real people would never come out here
and open up a restaurant
because here's a guy
like your dad who's 53 puts away his
life savings
but he has a secret pizza recipe every
time he makes his pizza people pull
their hairs out of that
he he borrows his money he borrows 10
000 from her
20 000 from me comes out here he gets a
great location he's making pizzas he's
making a great living man but he's
working six days a week though
this don't come easy and every day it's
a hundred [ __ ] pies
and also he's waiting there smoking a
cigarette outside and he sees a family
of three eating [ __ ] a box of
domino's pizza meanwhile this guy gets
the [ __ ]
cheese shipped in from milwaukee
he gets the nice tomatoes from a
communist garden you know san marzano
yeah you know what i'm saying that's
what happens and all saying you lose
faith and go why would i keep making
this quality when they're never going to
come over here
domino's has me with the advertising
there's 7.99 plus they get sausage
sticks
they get butterfucking out what else do
you get you get three chicken wings
cheesy bread
cheesy bread yeah
lava cake so that's the problem
and then there's suckers
then there's people who say i wouldn't
eat that [ __ ]
if i was on a [ __ ] island my mom says
my grandfather would roll over in his
grave oh if if we're in the olive garden
it's a very [ __ ] embarrassing thing
yeah
and that for people
listen when i go to pittsburgh i gotta
go to the olive garden
this place is like going i don't eat the
pasta i get the oil you can eat buns and
salad and soup
it's the best bread day you get that
imitation pasta fazool
and the salad let me tell you something
the best thing they have is that salad
do you know you could eat salad if it's
crispy if you go later
the thing sogs and the vinegar oil then
you have [ __ ] you have vinegar in all
soup no no no
when they first whack that [ __ ] up
it's not bad trust me i'm telling you
i've been in some dirk murk situations
in pittsburgh and it was right next to
the hotel it was [ __ ] snowing what do
you want me to walk around
i don't live in [ __ ] pittsburgh
there's a comedy club and there's a
[ __ ] whatever it's called what are we
talking about here
olive garden exactly
one person is paying attention where are
you headed late tonight i i knew we
olive garden but i thought i thought you
meant before i love gardening you want
another starley
is it time for another star oh it's
always just like this look at this we
haven't even put a dent in this this
weekend
you should be ashamed of yourself
messiah are you ready for start death
all right then
the body
the body of christ
it's like the exorcist lady tell them
the body of christ compels you
i gotta get a look at these little
warlocks the body of christ compels you
savage
savage
was that one
what let's give you one more the body of
christ
compounds you lisa
one more we're going deep can we spread
it no split what what
is the third grade splitting
we're going deep into the murky wars
lisa let me explain something to you
come on we go deep all year long this is
the the last four days before christmas
holiday that we're starting here
for cuban jews to take it back to egypt
this is it we're starting a new
organization for people who mean
business
this is the last four days before
hanukkah
this is
how are we gonna act how are you gonna
[ __ ] what do you wanna sing you wanna
do eat another star look at this the
body of christ
compels you you ever see the godfather
absolutely the first one before they
baptize and the priest goes
like this look
one more for the road dog like leonard
skinner [ __ ] it you got uber tonight
right this is gonna be interesting you
got money left on the lift card
i'm better
oh
[ __ ] leave it for the mouse but
nothing eat that one it's good for you
that one's got shoestrings up
oh i'm so high
that's over there
i got you lady
[Music]
don't lick your fingers right now
because
you're still in competition or something
don't it's okay there's some it's only
weed on it
oh my god come on put that bad boy away
they're gonna kick me out as soon as i
walk into the casino
it's gonna happen again
why not kick me out just look at my
oh okay eyes it
i said it's over
that's it you swallowed it you drink
some water you're right
you're really a bunny jack
i can do it i can do it one day
you still got it my body's like no
please
please don't do it oh
look at police
i want to take a minute and wish you
guys a a happy holidays and a merry
christmas and thank you for supporting
us all year
you guys are some great [ __ ] people
and uh
sometimes you just go off the rails here
look at me
holding on to his nose drinking this
last batch that's all these [ __ ]
you want to be sad be sad on your own
time there's no reason to be sad come on
you got family you got peeps and [ __ ]
people get sad this time of the year
you gotta do the opposite take a deep
breath look for the future and get ready
to get your dick sucked that's all you
can think about you know what i'm saying
you're looking straight ahead [ __ ] these
mother how you feeling lee
look at you and so this is christmas
goalie that's it
and what have you done now you could say
and whatever you've done tell them what
have you done oh dean we you did
huh you did 1500 milligrams so what we
did oh 400 days before hanukkah
and that's what you did 400.
all right so when do you want when you
expect to fight next i don't know may
this is a they'll suspend you because of
the stitches that that yeah 60-day thing
yeah yeah i don't know i don't get back
at it though keep everyone up
jelly sandwich and the stitches heal
yeah you're ready to go gee money it's
all over
six days a week jack it's true when
you're 24 what do you mean roast beef
sandwich
a little peroxide you drink some
peroxide you're back
[ __ ] yeah hell yeah
that's uh you're in a good position and
a good time everything will peak
perfectly and you'll be right there to
[ __ ]
claim jersey and [ __ ]
with the miller brothers [ __ ] it up
mm-hmm
lee how are we doing over there all
right
you're turning redder by the minute can
do you understand changes
you look like you know how to sing you
look like you'd be good at character
okay yes yes you're mickey oh thank you
i don't know how to what changes changes
is a song
that ozzy os was saying why he was a
black sabbath in 1980 and 19 like this
the third um how the [ __ ] knows
and it's called it's called i'm going
through changes it's called changes
but the main lyrics is going through
changes one that i'm sitting here he's
eating edibles like he's 10 over there
i'm talking to the guest like yourself
and i'm looking at his face and i could
see him
like thinking of his life like you know
look at your face you get like oh yeah i
was ten like he had that but he really
couldn't talk or he had the microphone
though
and also i looked at him like a leak and
also he came out of it what and i know
you're going through changes aren't you
i said you're right so he's over there
going through changes right now i just
saw him
a few minutes ago
those last two stars
i'm trying to find all right so now you
go you go right back in it
you go back to five a day six of days
yeah i do i've been training the whole
thing yeah i do um i'll do double
sessions five days a week i used to do
six
i used to do i usually like six and then
just one day off by like two days off so
i'll do monday to friday double sessions
practice in the morning go eat some food
practice tonight in your position you
want to fight twice a year
maybe a little more this time i fought
three okay last time yeah i thought
i i i probably could have done four
because it made me they gave me a big
break between i fought in uh i thought
february 6 and i didn't fight till
september i wanted to fight that summer
but it made me wait for punk
no i'm saying i think that's a big break
yeah i would like to so i i think i
could do three four a year
you can move them quickly yeah you know
you can move it quickly especially the
way you're training and whatnot
no you look great yeah i mean like i
said i knew you were fighting but i
didn't see the
countdown to the following morning
and i'm like this [ __ ] kid is uh
the real [ __ ] deal thanks man he went
in there were you another dog or you
were a favorite i think it was it's
pretty even was it really yeah i think
uh
by the time we fought i think i was like
a minus 140 and he was like a plus 120
[Music]
plus 100 something like even you know
yeah
okay
yeah so not much pretty pretty pretty
pick them pick them fight
oh millennium how you [ __ ] finish
them
yeah do that big
i could do that and i could do that to
anyone in the world
drop him with a big shot choke him out
once you hit him with that big shout
what is it
what is it about the shot
that you know that you have
six seconds to put the cobra hooks of
death
into them oh whatever right as i hit him
he went right down his butt sat him
right down and then he like took he like
i could tell he was like on queer street
because he took that little dive at me
so i threw like an uppercut he started
to protect his neck spun to the back and
he that whole time he he wasn't firing
he wasn't moving right he's [ __ ] up
from the shot
yeah you that's that's that you just
[ __ ] spawned on him like a
yeah like a [ __ ] this is just
yeah
georgia and i was like oh my god this is
pretty goddamn amazing
i can't even think of making a move like
that what's up it was a good fight and i
i just i don't remember the his the the
guy's name but the cub spawns in the
fight his opponent called him out and he
cubs swanson ended up winning
have you ever thought like is it a lot
of pressure to win when you call someone
out or is it not really yeah but it's
just pressure anyway you know what i
mean like anyway like when you're in the
back you're nervous as heck whether it's
you know you called him out and talked a
bunch of [ __ ] or you know what i mean
you don't want to get beat up
from all your people anyway
right well yeah well you never want to
lose no heck no no no listen if you look
at the ufc's history
the last three years in the growth
you got to talk a little bit
yeah you got to be like not just an
athlete but an entertainer yeah you got
to talk a little bit
i mean you can't [ __ ] dye your hand
like your feet on fire
and go in there because now you put more
attention to the entertainment than you
are the fight
but this uh a light walk
there's uh it's it's funny in the old
days whenever i saw a fighter going with
dyed hair
i would go [ __ ] i should have been on
the other guy and sure enough the guy
would die they would lose
because they focused on the red thinking
about your hair what the [ __ ] guy
you're supposed to be thinking about the
goddamn fight little things like that
and maybe i was wrong a few times but
for the most part
any guy that walked in there with pink
hair or
a show three guys bowing in front of him
over and quick too
quick like
and you're like holy [ __ ] he focused
more on the entrance
than the whole fight i used to think
that in uh i wrestled my senior year and
when people would see the wrestlers with
the tattoos they'd be like oh i bet he's
good well that means he was sitting in a
tattoo chair when i was out here lifting
or throwing someone around you know what
i mean
it's really [ __ ] up the influence
of the tattoo the last 20 years yeah
like
up to the time i went out of prison
the only way you had a tattoo is if you
were in prison or you were
a [ __ ] uh
uh they captured you in cuba
or the chinese dudes or the japanese
yakuza and [ __ ] and all of a sudden it
just went awol
everybody got tattoos they're everywhere
it is
you could not predict this 30 years ago
people gonna be having tattoos people go
get the [ __ ] out of here
because there was such a
not a taboo against it but yeah oh
you're right you got a stigma there was
a stigma about it you you met my mom and
joey my mom hates tattoos listen to me
i went with a friend of mine
we talked we got all coked up the night
before we were 16
and i was gonna put coco on my knuckles
like ozzy osbourne put ozzy
and we walked all the way up there and
something was like
someday i'm gonna want to get a [ __ ]
job man
and that's not they're gonna look at my
hands and i go you know what i already
got enough [ __ ]
[ __ ] against me at this age
the last thing i need is to put my
[ __ ] knuckle up my hands and
you know what i would have fainted
anyway i can't see needles
so in a way i'm kind of happy then
i got a buddy like that what's that they
can't see this passes out yeah i could
never be i don't care how good of a
fighter i was
i could never ever be in the ufc
play any professional sports anything
because i could i don't know how i'm
going to react at certain situations
i don't know how i'm going to react at
certain situations
i might see you get your head punched
off and i might just walk away
i might see you get hit
and your coach wipe your eye
and then throw the towel down in a live
thing
and i'll look at the amount of blood on
the towel
and i'll have a nervous breakdown do you
follow me
so i don't like that [ __ ] no more i
[ __ ] it i fainted one live ufc
and i fainted one time at home watching
a live view of a ufc event
the fight i fainted to that it was one
of those lap palm fights the palms the
palm and i was there with ralphie may
all right ralphie was performing in
vegas i asked joe for a ticket he's
sitting there it's me ralphie some chick
with big fake tits
next to a doctor thank god
same thing happened it was a fight they
fought the one guy opened the other guy
up i watched the whole thing go down i
heard the skin break
damn the guy
i heard the whole [ __ ] thing go down
you know i heard them the announcers
kind of saying he's cut he's caught
whatever the [ __ ] and also i saw him get
up and i saw the coach when as soon as
he got up the doctor comes over to you
and puts his stitch whoever puts the
thing over the eye and when he got to
the corner he sat down he threw that
down
and my mind went down with the towel and
i saw there was no towel it was just all
blood
and also the next thing you know they're
waking me up they get water and [ __ ]
what about when they have like
when they're covering up the cut and
then they open it up and then it like
squirts a little bit have you seen that
happen from time to time but i don't
really focus on it once i see a towel
over something i go for a [ __ ] soda
or [ __ ] water or something you
understand me i don't sit there and wait
and watch the blood squirt out of his
[ __ ] head and i see it sometimes they
get punched and you see the blood i
don't bother to watch the replay i saw
it already i saw it squirt out you see a
mouthpiece fly out
things like that i don't want to see the
[ __ ] guy squirt sometimes i i watch
it and guess what he's bleeding to death
and nothing happens
so
that's why i don't like watching that
[ __ ] because i don't know how i'm going
to react
anything about that thing
what do you think that lisa you don't
even know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about for christ's sake what are you
gonna do after you leave here
i'm gonna go home and get some reese i
want to give her a happy holiday shout
out
to all the [ __ ] people who
listen to this podcast
like i said i know there's a heavy time
of the year
you know what i love you and everything
like that but snap out of it [ __ ]
2017 is coming it's over i want to give
a big shout out to my man matt homer
homemeyer and lorne rosenker and darcy j
watt
and arse warrior and
alibaz and colin carmen
and johnny utah and tal jaffee brookie
and [ __ ] uki spooky dominoki
and uh you know all the [ __ ] my
people in austin you know i love you
[ __ ] with all my heart man
thank you for listening every week and
[ __ ] like that
and that's it man what was your next
plan of attack
do you need me
you're just gonna keep fighting i don't
want to [ __ ] fight no films no
nothing you got time [ __ ] keep fighting
that's right
just tell the [ __ ] you know
what
i'll tell you what i will do
say listen
give me 20 mil to hold me
i'm 24 and i'm 28 i'll be worth double
that
and i'll give you three films
but they all got to be charles bronson
remake so i'm gonna choose them
boom [ __ ] and i choose them boom and
we gotta remake them uncle joey takes
like charles bronson would do it
to his extent at that next level how
would he do
death wish now with what's going on in
new york you know what i'm saying will
he just buy sticks and dynamite and
throw them at [ __ ] like
surprise and just blow [ __ ] up
if we're gonna start remaking
something let's remake it even better
you know but let's keep it how these
[ __ ] would do it they're gonna
remake everything they're gonna make the
honeymooners
you do know that right they rebooted the
honeymooners on cbs
to a guy like me that would be a
complete slap in the face man
unless i play [ __ ] ralph graham
the right way but he always says he's
going to send it to the moon
he can't say those things
he can't say a lot of things yeah he
would say that's true yeah
he can't say no bang zoom one day alice
he can't threaten her
almost he can't call norton stupid
none of that stuff there was never any
but they would see there was brilliant
episodes of the honeymooners see the
honeymooners at the end of
at the end of saturday night live
it's a great show and all but count how
many [ __ ] writers they have
when you watch the honeymooners it's two
writers and jackie gleason
you grew up on the honeymooners
you i've seen it but i didn't grow up
you grow up
see what kind of generation this is what
i'm [ __ ] talking about and they're on
wpix yeah constantly and [ __ ]
listen before you get into the other
comic
watch cert like christmas day and watch
jackie gleason all right god damn that's
a good episode yeah they got my uh
tapes it's a marathon it's a marathon in
jersey all day on wednesday on saturday
that's what you do christmas day
you to go for a walk you get tuned up
you come back you spray banaca [ __ ]
mouthwash and [ __ ] you put visine in
your eyeballs where'd you go i was
worried about you i had to go for a walk
there was burglars in the neighborhood
a couple of humans and puerto ricans and
[ __ ] they were driving they were playing
that labor music
and also they're like let me cook for
you you sit down and there's the
honeymooners you take your shoes off
they make your hot cocoa and you don't
go nowhere if you're really [ __ ]
lucky on christmas day you got march of
the wooden soldiers
with [ __ ] which they play but
see people wouldn't watch that [ __ ]
today you guys wouldn't even think of
watching that [ __ ] today that's history
right there little gives a frenchman's
[ __ ] lee what do you got planned for
christmas eve christmas eve well that's
the big one for paula's mom so what's
she doing she making
uh she's gonna go to she
is it christmas tamales i don't know
what it is i'm pretty sure it's tamales
so christmas eve you're going over there
oh yeah and what are you doing christmas
day
no plans is right now look at you you
said tamales on christmas on christmas
eve your girl mexican yeah okay
okay yeah i'm into uh people are gonna
get mad i like tamales my favorite are
the sweet ones though
i'm not like the the the masa thing is
real heavy for me i like it though
i don't know
how you you try to eat 18 plates of
tamales 18 [ __ ] plates
doesn't stop you look at you look at two
tamales you go let me get red one pork
and let me get a green one a little
spicy
you pull them in you put a little sauce
on that [ __ ] a little bit of
cheese to dilute the [ __ ] spiciness
and you eat them like a soldier you say
they're very good and you walk away yeah
you do that but then her mom serves him
with rice and then her mom comes by and
gives you more what type of rice yellow
wrecked mexican rice of course so you
eat it lee what the [ __ ] i do go back
home you do some kettlebells on the
balcony and you balance it out
you know what i'm saying why are you
playing games with me for
you know how it's done
it's you that you go bananas i know and
i would go bananas too but you can't you
got to control yourself you're a savage
you're
you're a student of the game
[ __ ] blue apron i know i am are
you gonna be eating blue apron and then
go over there
i need 18 tamales
i can't eat 18 tamales that's my point
what type of loyalty we talking about my
buddy larry got me a hotel where they
have cheeseburgers for 2.99 oh my gosh i
know and i know he already yelped it and
everything other cheeseburgers made a
goat or [ __ ]
armenian meat that was killed in
glendale and
[ __ ] mafia meat dipped in whatever
what do you go as my main little brother
champ
be champ
keep winning
make some money one step at a time my
friend you got all the [ __ ] utensils
you got sidekicks for jesus yes sir
uncle joey will be talking about you
thank you when i go to jersey i'll be
dropping your name what [ __ ] i don't
know so you're moving to lightweight
yeah yeah so i'm dropping down two
jersey guys in the lightweight division
so what are you weighing now
like uh so i can make 170 pretty easy
but when i walk around i'm at like 190.
but if i if i diet and like stay on my
like fight camp diet just a little
longer
just do the what drop the water
that'd be a chance you want to go down
to 155 yeah think about it
no [ __ ] think about it yeah think about
it yeah jim jim miller
told me i should
uh my buddy billy d told me i should
i and i i think i i could you know i'll
have i'll eventually be able to be the
champion 72
70 as well but i think i could be a
champion 55 in like a couple years a
year or two that'll be huge so for you
to fight at 155
to be honest it's not [ __ ]
you need to walk around at 170. i know
that's the fight week i'm good i got
easier said than done when you live in
new jersey though yes right i gotta be
like disciplined like i gotta have a
crappy month i'm not gonna enjoy food
but then after like now like i'm in that
spot where i could eat you know what are
you weighing now
right now probably i'm probably about
like 90 right now so once you go into
camp what do you eat what kind of
breakfast i just i switch it up i go
clean clean i i only do like carbs i
gotta do rice only like before and after
workouts
like if i like and if i go to 55 i'll
have to i'll do that and i'll just
portion i'm just like i'm gonna go bone
like i'll crush
i'll eat a lot when i eat you know so i
just gotta k put it like i'll overdo it
if i control like my portions and
whatnot i i could be all right oh it's
so weird like
when you're in high school when you get
out those college years you're still
working out with the high school
intensity you could [ __ ] eat dog
you could eat you know i used to eat a
box of cereal like nothing it's crushing
it like nothing box of cereal two eggs
bread bacon and walk around like nothing
no farting
no [ __ ] and afterward like i could still
put away another eight ounces or
whatever yeah yeah i'm saying
i kept it low just in case i bump into
something just in case i go over to
mickey's house and then mom's got a
cheese on it with potatoes or something
and she invites me in i can't deny it
i'm not gonna disrespect her and [ __ ]
like that
dog i wish you all the [ __ ] luck in
the world thanks man i appreciate it
it's cool to be on here talking about a
big fan it was cool to have you on and
stuff
garnett i want to thank garnett yeah
together he's a good [ __ ] man yeah
let me just do two things here and you
get out of here go eat go jump up and
down
do what you do let's be honest
most of your problems start with the
mind all right fear anger stress anxiety
depression and sleeplessness they begin
in your head but they can wreck your
life but it doesn't have to be that way
you can make a major difference in 10
minutes a day
headspace is meditation
made simple it's guided meditations you
listen to whenever you want wherever you
want right on your phone computer or
tablet
it's rooted in thousands of years of
tradition with thousands of specific
studies that show its positive effects
like improving focus
relationship
and harmony
join over 4 million users already
getting headspace for free right now
download the free headspace app
and begin the take 10 program
for 10 days of guided meditation at
headspace.com
joey again the headspace takes
10 program is 100 freeway to experience
the benefits of meditation in your busy
modern life train your mind for a
healthier less stressed life start your
free trial today at headspace.com
joey that's headspace.com
joey i want to give a shout out to these
[ __ ] savages
because i love them with all my heart
again
the bidet is back [ __ ] i don't know
if you people know it you're ready to
get the dream gift a bidet is back do
you know what a bidet does no you don't
you strap it onto your toilet it's
portable you don't even need a plumber
you do nothing you strap it on you tap
some [ __ ] screws and next thing you
know next time you walk 10 miles next
time you take a big dump you know
sometimes you take a dump and even if
you wipe your muffler you leave that
room and you're like you know what
something right
even though i took a shower 20 minutes
ago you ever take a nice shower
you put your clothes on so you got to
take a [ __ ] and you're like what'd i
take a shower for god might as well
start your day over yeah i would worry
now now you walk around and you're
self-conscious you got rotten ass
no more
and now you can hit it again in 20
minutes because sometimes you wipe your
ass but mysteriously you go for a walk
or something or a long job and also you
get rotten ass all over again those days
are done before you even leave the house
you hit that little [ __ ] muffler with
some water and bam
no [ __ ] germs no swamp ass
no nothing tell em lee
break it down for them
i like it i i start my day with it i i
shower after i work out but
dude
i when i wake up in the middle of the
night sometimes i turn the heat on
because in the morning it's [ __ ] cold
so but then i get all cuddly in bed and
i get sweaty and that's not nice so
before i go to the gym i always you it's
great i start every day with it and you
know what it's fresh water and it cleans
your muffler you know what i'm saying
because sometimes you're sitting there
overnight you get that rotten and you're
going to starbucks you try to order
coffee there's a girl funny attractive
woman and she's with some [ __ ] uh
johnny harvey
he you know he gave her a stabbing the
night before but she spent the night but
she didn't take a shower how do you know
because she's got that ratness behind
her head and you're sitting there going
this chick didn't even wash that monkey
this morning
no more you go listen honey i gave you a
stabbing last night watch that [ __ ]
rotten condom smell out of your muffler
with [ __ ]
hit that bidet baby you don't gotta walk
around with that dead [ __ ] condom
skunk and your little monkey
what i'm trying to say
is go to hellotushy.com
right now slash
church [ __ ] get 10 off your order you
need this for the stocking stuffers the
stocking stuffers whatever the stuff and
stuff is whatever you're selling
whatever the [ __ ] you stop
you can get hellotushy.com
yeah slash
church oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
it's a beautiful night to be alive
listen this is the gift you've been
looking for everybody wants to know you
know what i worked hard all year what i
want to get myself i need another tv for
the bedroom that's going to disrupt my
sleep i need a new car like i need to
commit suicide you know what
really i'm gonna buy a new car to pay
1800 a year insurance and to get tickets
out of buck 20 your [ __ ] bank [ __ ]
you you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
get myself a bidet i'm gonna [ __ ]
take a [ __ ] from now on and just sit
there with hot water
sprinkling my [ __ ] i'm gonna turn the
lights off i'm gonna put my feet up i'm
gonna see if i can order some chinese
woman for 22 an hour i can kind of cure
my feet with hot water hitting my ass so
that's a [ __ ] goal you want to
achieve in 2017 and i'm giving it to you
tonight
hellotushy.com
church bam 10 off
one more time headspace and my main
[ __ ] is over and on it throwing
heat go over there for the supplements
i'm telling you you're getting into jiu
jitsu get that shroom tech sport and
[ __ ] take two of those take them
before my fights yeah team all the time
love it i'm telling you you're jumping
up and down
everything's beautiful all right go to
on it and slash in church boom and get
ten percent off delivered to your house
who's better than your uncle joey boxes
nobody i just got your shroom checked
and i'm like yeah [ __ ] washed like
that
i don't even know what the [ __ ] i'm
trying to put together yo merry
christmas from the bottom of my heart to
all of you [ __ ] the lingus is
that
it's just too much bob lalingas what are
you laughing about i love it the chicago
mafia 10th planet [ __ ] uh dead squad
[ __ ] uh my man mickey golf family and
his sisters you guys you bad
[ __ ]
thank you for coming on for you
listening
for you listening to the stories where
you listening to our
racist and disgusting remarks and not
reporting this to the irs
for many reasons you understand me we
love you man
and i can cut this out from monster most
insane is is your ari show coming up
soon and this is the last tomorrow night
that's right look at lee syed
look look at lisa the assistant for the
assistant to the assistant to the
assistant to the assistant show director
it is so again
okay can for that
and the last show and one of the last
shows of the year maybe turn on your
vcr's
right now when you download this it's
wednesday do me a favor i'm on this is
not happening but go ahead dory i'm
sorry sorry to interrupt you my brother
no i was just saying can i get one of
the assistants cut off
for that assist okay you're the
assistant to the assistant to the
assistant to the assistant how's that
making new business cards
just put scott's case and i want to
thank you for coming on thank you you
made a fan the believer out of me and uh
you did in a weird way
because i watched that footage next you
know you're fighting them
and i didn't understand if you had
fought and i missed it
i'm like well how the [ __ ] did where the
[ __ ] have i been do i smoke that much
marijuana and then after what i realized
and you were fighting again i'm like
look at him this [ __ ] was going
for people's calling for it oh [ __ ]
little by little like a jersey
[ __ ] like sinatra fresh in
hoboken on 19th street he said [ __ ] i
ain't letting these people hold me down
what the [ __ ] am i talking about i'm not
doing edibles no more
show you understand me merry christmas
and we'll be back next week we are doing
a podcast next week it's a surprise
[ __ ] podcast for you [ __ ] i
love you guys have a great weekend have
a great time for your families thank you
for supporting us play something
make something up okay
it took you too long you slip and say
well
uh what happened
[Music]
you